non avec
je suis l'enfant de la guerre je suis né
dedans
les gens croient comprendre la douleur
ils savent même pas ce que c'est tapirs
douleur à toi c'est quoi ce serait
peut-être celle qui fait de toi une
machine que tôt qu'un homme après non
stop
mais c'est quoi ça gbagbo pourquoi il
manque les effets spéciaux son bras il
est censé être en métal c'est pas comme
s'il suffisait dépasser une moustache
je vais le faire moi même je suis diable
je viens que futur et je suis toujours
vénère cobayes non pas nous arrive
d'être pour eux tu sais tu étais
beaucoup plus grand dans la terre basque
revient au pouvoir de régénération
active et ça je dis pas ça fermait la
accable groupe est en fonte à ton
service
on ne meurt pas
déjà prêt à bas ce fut rapide bon une
fois très bien envoyé
[Musique]
là
c'est fini pour toi blaireau là c'est le
dialoguiste qui s'est pas foulée
[Musique]